what do you do for a living with a
biceps
Logistics it's a logistics question how
you put that tight ass shirt on
is that how you met her at your
Logistics job
you guys been in elementary school oh my
God that's adorable you guys married
what's that about bro you know her 40
years you can't marry her yet
much more you got to know dog
he did this I don't know what that means
I think he's saying I'll rip your throat
out you keep talking to me what's
helping you up that's a logistical
question again I would love to know the
answer too
you're his boss hey Jesus girl I like
that little sexual harassment I love
that I love that
[Applause]